[Music]
in filter fail news
submitted by love and basketball i like
them
with leonardo dicaprio no that's the
basketball diaries oh it was one of the
epic brothers
that's a good movie is that omar epps
yes is it yeah
okay a vlogger who used a filter to look
younger was caught
in a live stream glitch oh
no gina say you
wait there's younger filters on
livestream watch it's the baby one and
everyone thought it was
like they have a kids channel yeah
that's funny or the reverse age one
like the red woman oh i want that when
i'm old as [ __ ]
you're talking about the game of thrones
thing right melisandre you know who has
that in real life madonna
okay well i mean she should look 90 but
then she looks like what 50. i agree i
want him
i mean she looks kind of skeletony but
she is 50 or something
no she's way older than jayla's 50. oh
[ __ ] you're right
madonna's like 70 years old oh my god
that's true i want to see the chart
though i wish that they had to wear
nascar
like outfits with all the surgeries they
had done
like the sponsorships yeah i want to see
oh that's interesting i like that
you just uh converted to the cabal and
stuff and then there you go
you oh you think sometimes oh because
it's that red string thing right yeah i
don't know the cabal
is like a occult kind of thing but like
yeah okay anyway we're getting too far
over there yeah so
this is a popular chinese video blogger
and she calls herself your highness
i don't know i tried but she has this
young
filter on when she live streamed and it
actually did a video glitch
and it turns out that she's a
middleweight woman whoa
oh my absolute god it changed her
clothes that's like mom and daughter
no this is like from a different date
how did they change her chin shape
you like changed her whole jaw that's
mom and daughter the
[ __ ] wait why is her shirt different she
was live streaming with this other chick
and that's when she had her glitch
happen she didn't even react to it
she was just like wait what does she
usually look like the one on the right i
bet you the one on the left
looks just like that too that's why wow
you're right oh cause that's oh that's
the shirt i see oh [ __ ]
that's the melisandre thing you've said
yeah is that
her yeah she's cute they're saying like
you know she always has this really
young voice hello everybody yeah she
even tries to be like
semi-sorta like sexual
and so she ends up getting a lot of
donations from her followers
and during this one live stream she was
saying like you know
um i i can't show my face until i
receive
gifts worth 100 000 yuan
after all i am a good host and so she
was out there you say hello
and i'm a good-looking house they were
saying that she had been
worshipped as a cute goddess that's
their fault
not hers that's exactly what other
people are saying they're like wow
like the people donating to her are the
idiots but do they get refunds because
she's not that hot so a lot of people
pull their gifts back like yeah they
work
that's so funny that's appropriate they
can't hey but if they
came to her already i feel like she
deserves them
like came as in like oh it's like that
guy that was
uh like an anime girl or something yeah
yeah and then he broke
yeah like did the glitch forgot about
that yeah damn glitches man ruining
people's
careers that's what they get from doing
live live stuff though
you can't get wreck-it ralph no spoilers
go watch it
but you know it is entertainment though
i mean what's the difference between
that
and like back in the theater days when
guys
pretended to be women yeah and they took
their wig off yeah and but dudes would
fall in love with that character but
that's because there was no good female
actors though that's true
girls aren't that good yeah yeah i had
to develop that skill that's true but
yeah they're saying that this chick was
renowned for her sweet and healing voice
and so once they found out what she
really looked like
people just started pulling out like
crazy and she didn't realize about the
glitch
until she noticed that in her vip
section so many people bounced that's
when she was like what the [ __ ] was
going on
video killed the radio star because they
saw her they're like oh they started
vomiting i can't believe i jerked you
oh you're like my mom it was like that
it's like that it's ventura scene where
you realize
you kissed a dude
and everyone starts throwing up when
they like he turns except finkel was
hotter than this lady
yeah that's true i think i find but yeah
so then
in across chinese social media networks
they all started using
this hashtag that translates to female
vlogger experiencing
experiences bug showing her old lady
face it's a hashtag
yeah it's the longest hashtag i've ever
heard maybe it's like three chinese
characters though
i don't even know chinese people use
hashtags yeah they do oh wow
yeah and then it just looks like another
choice yeah it looks like another
chinese character
and so they're saying that they've used
it more than 50 000 times
and yeah but this whole thing so she
ended up
like shutting down her stuff she just
has to create a new persona yeah come
back she's good at it or her voice is
really known maybe she can't she
couldn't change her voice
if she changed it that way she could
change it another way yeah she can give
her her new character an adam's apple
and then do a deeper voice
yeah she can do like sexy yeah i like
that
he's like hey welcome to the stream
that's good can you do that
while speaking chinese because i'm
curious what that sounds like
like a deep voice
[Laughter]
what did you say i said hey do you want
to eat lunch i'm pretty hungry
oh damn dude i was reading this
uh thing actually um about how
names that have a deeper syllable in
them um
are sexier like subliminally it's like
like an o in it
to people
yeah like things that are like uh the
lower
syllables like people for some reason
fine versus like
yeah yeah like the acupressure of
glasses while you're saying
ariel
ariel or like oreo oreo
i don't know dude i want to design a
nicky sex robot but she talks in the
nicky
uh jersey accent joycey you want me to
do it yeah i do
well what do you want me to say this is
the usual the usual
he likes the live remote of wall street
sorry
daddy
yeah i probably know how to say that i
know that's pretty good
you wanted a guido wife you wanted a
guido life you wanted
you wanted a jersey shore girl i got it
i think visually i used to have this bit
where like when i was single
and uh like i just had my cats and i
wanted them to cuddle me
i'd be like come here frankie big boy
come on get some jersey [ __ ] right there
i like it it's like
like old-fashioned bedding betty boo
yeah
oh don't you like me anymore frankie
i like i had to see my cat he'd be like
sitting in the chair he's like
you need the hands too yeah with his
[ __ ] tail [ __ ] you crazy
come on frankie because his name's
franklin yeah [ __ ] cute
what's different from this and like
performance art i think it's like the
same [ __ ] right
i think it's a different understanding
people think it's real yeah you know
it's like a theater
this one people are trying to really
like masturbate yeah ejaculate to this
who they thought was
well and it's fraud she defrauded these
fine young men yeah exactly
i mean like pretty much this is like the
same [ __ ] as cam growing to me
like well this is non-sexual it could be
more like i think the problem here the
companionship they they feel cheated
because they're like wait i thought you
were this you never told me you were
there they thought it was a real person
i thought your ass was like this not
like this it's like when comedians kill
themselves and they're like how did that
happen
he's so funny and happy that's true and
they're like they don't
get that they're sad people i think the
average person doesn't understand that
the minute you're on the other side of
the camera there's already like
all an altered reality yeah that's what
most people don't understand they're
like a bunch of toddlers and like this
is like the mom
going and then all of a sudden she goes
and they're like no
yeah yeah well it's also like when you
find out that like your parents have sex
and [ __ ]
like that they're real people too and
that they have urges and things that you
don't think about when you're a kid
you're just no
well it's very normal they're not humans
i know but it's very natural they're
providers you guys got brainwashed that
way
and that's too bad i think it's a very
positive thing yeah i always knew that
my parents
got it on yeah because i remember
looking through family photos
and there's some photos that i've come
across over what if they weren't nude
but it would be like my mom like with
her leg coming out and like she's naked
under the sheet but like the sheets
covering everything
oh wow she's like asleep and i'm like ew
did they just finish having sex and they
took a photo to a commemorator
it's like your mom like on her knees and
your dad's like this like with like
fully clothed and she's like
oh my god our kids are gonna see all
those pictures
dude what if it was just an album of all
your mom sleeping in different positions
and she doesn't even know about it no
there were some
creepy there was this other one where
she was on the toilet too and i was like
why are my dad taking like butt naked is
she looking at the camera she was kind
of like embarrassed like kind of thing
but
if she wasn't looking at the camera like
yeah it's a whole album of her on the
toilet
it's yeah it's from like the ceiling and
[ __ ] i guess she's super late views
yeah like once from underneath they're
black and white they're kind of grainy
there's just upskirts they're not that
old yeah your dad used to dress up like
a toilet with a camera
there were these other ones too that
they took selfies of like them like
making out like their tongues are
like yeah they took selfies yeah and you
looked at a lot of pictures
they're in a family album but you kept
going you're [ __ ] hurt
you're a weirdo you kept on going
because they're all mixed up like you
know like the printed ones they're all
like from different days
you don't have to justify yourself but
i'm just like looking through i'm like
oh cool like some from my kindergarten
i'm like wait another one of them when
they your parents aren't very organized
the first one i see of my mom naked in
bed i'm putting the album down and
walking
oh i'm curious as [ __ ] though one time i
stumbled upon this like lunchbox looking
thingy in my parents closet it was way
up on the top shelf i'm like ooh look at
that lunchbox cool it's cool
why would they do it so it's inviting to
kids i don't know i don't know
but um i opened it and it was a bunch of
love letters that my dad used to write
my mom when they lived
when he lived in los angeles and she
lived in santa barbara and it's all of
them are like i'm so horny
i can't wait till my [ __ ] i like how
quickly we
turned i wanted to know you kept reading
instead of having phone sex they had
[ __ ] letter sex
it's not texting it's like male sex what
the [ __ ] is that i had just learned the
word horny because in the sublime songs
they talk about it and so
i just found out what that word meant
and so then i
got it dude what do you think they did
in the civil war though man they're
writing all kinds of letters for their
wives
dearest agatha my pants are very tight
in the battlefield
you know they're saying i yearn for your
loincloth
[ __ ] yeah brother samuel starting to
look like you yeah right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you